the UK is a significant global economy
but it's far from being the biggest so
it doesn't that often make headlines all
around the world but it did this week
although maybe not for the right reasons
this morning the British pound plunged
nearly five percent to a record low
against the US dollar British pound has
crashed to a record low against the U.S
dollar the British pound hitting an
all-time low today against the dollar
yeah so here's what happened Liz truss
introduced a round of tax cuts for the
wealthy and in response the British
currency has collapsed I think the UK is
behaving a bit like an emerging market
do we have the ingredients required to
have that self-fulfilling downward
spiral
I think it's something worse
unfortunately I don't want it to be
worse this is the country I earn my
money in I'm long Sterling and naturally
from my my salary this is a UK fueling a
global development that is resulting in
significant damage both to Global
markets and the global economy and over
the weekend the the chancellor in a
Schoolboy era then says more of this
stuff is coming and so chaos Reigns
I wonder if the new prime minister Liz
truss was watching a little earlier I
spoke to the man that some call her
favorite Economist that's Jared Lyons
and I started by asking if the
government is right by trying to say
this turmoil is primarily down to Global
forces
the reality is that there's three
different things happening uh first the
government is right the global backdrop
is very difficult very febrile financial
markets and interest rates in the
western economies and borrowing rates of
Western economies have risen
significantly in recent months then
second on top of that last Thursday the
bank of England increased interest rates
in the UK by not as much as the markets
probably had hoped for but at the same
time the bank of England said that they
were going to be selling guilts over the
next year which the markets didn't like
that added to the supply of government
debt but the third factor in particular
was the mini budget so one has to say of
all the events it was the mini budget
that was the most significant but the
backdrop was both those global factors
in the Bank of England last Thursday and
in terms of the mini budget there were
lots of good things in the many budget
in terms of aims at the pro-growth
agenda Confederation the British
industry like to The Institute of
directors liked it that as I warned
about beforehand and as I was worried
out on Dave and as the markets are now
showing the bank at the markets were not
liking the fact that the government
borrowed too much they announced the
whole series of measures that the market
expected but then they went that one
extra step they announced some tax
changes that the markets were not
comfortable with I think the markets
were overly worried about the
inflationary implications of those extra
tax changes but in particular and I can
understand that the markets were worried
about the affordability largely because
they were not prepared for it so for
instance the tax change for higher
earners in economic terms was not so
significant but it was like the last
straw that broke the camels back the
chancellor while he had focused on the
general public and on British businesses
he had not really prepared the financial
markets fully and I think he had taken
his eye off the ball slightly shall we
say in having not prepared the markets
for what he was doing in the budget and
I felt that he overstepped the mark last
week so it was the combination of all
three factors the febrile markets
because the global backdrop the actions
of the bank of England last Thursday but
let's be no doubt it was primarily the
mini budget last Friday that triggered
this later series of events
I have to say listening to you I am
quite struck by the change in the
attitude that I am seeing when we spoke
before the budget
um it felt to me like you were quite
excited about the Liz trust economic
plan and you were excited about the fact
that it was gonna in your view help
growth now you're saying that the
chancellor is overstepped the mark and
there was things in the budget
specifically that have frightened the
markets
um have you changed your view
no no let's be quite clear
um it was very positive in many respects
the budget or the mini budget last
Friday because the mini budget was very
much either a pro growth agenda and
that's really good we need to break out
of this low growth phase and we need to
move to a more supply side driven
investment-led agenda
the challenge though was that as one
moved towards the budget last Friday
particularly given the backdrop
internationally and that the bank of
England as I said the bank of England
tightening policy it was vitally
important I would say that the
government or the chancellor took the
financial markets with him I was writing
last week in particular in the week
before about the very febrile state of
the markets so coming back to your
question though there was a whole series
of very positive things in the many
budget but what one needs to say is that
if we take three different Target
audiences general public now the mini
budget really helped them because by
having the energy price tap and by
reversing those planned tax increases
corporation tax and National Insurance
the combination of all that effectively
have stopped the economy falling into a
potentially very deep recession and stop
things falling into a situation where
the public finances would have been
blown out of the water now the second
target audience was the British business
community and as I say the CBI
Confederation British industry the
district directors were very positive
and that's because there were lots of
very pro-investment measures announced
in the budget and the marker for further
steps in the future that was really good
but the third group was the markets were
very nervous ahead of budget now if the
chancellor had just stuck to what the
markets had expected which is actually
what I thought he was going to do then
it would have all been fine so in
addition to the energy app of the
additional borrowing 82 pence in each
extra pounds borrowed was reversing
those two plan tax increases if it had
just been that it would have been really
fine but what we saw was maybe for
whatever reason the chancellor just
decided to do a little bit more and in
and themselves you might say each
individual item wasn't particularly
expensive but it was the fact that the
markets were in the three bar of state
and they were worried about the
affordability the ability to service the
debts shall we say so overall lots of
positives it wasn't communicated well
and maybe not handled well at the last
minute but putting it all together
coming back to your question I think the
pro-growth strategy is very good but
what we now have is the aftermath of the
events of last week and what we need to
see is a period of stability returned to
financial markets you say that a period
of stability is needed do you think
spending cuts are necessary
um well in terms of that that's not the
immediate issue in my mind when one
looks at fiscal policy and I'm surprised
we're having to wait till late November
the fiscal principles I think are very
important physical principles are very
much about stabilizing the economy in
the near term so he should do something
quicker you think then well actually
last Friday he announced measures to
stabilize the economy in the near term
by ruling out the Deep recession but
what I'm saying in terms of Quaker in
terms of bringing those principles
forward just because if you can the
principles are quite clear it's about
having fiscal discipline and that's
about reducing debt to GDP you said that
you warned before the budget about the
risks of borrowing and also the risk of
not taking the markets along with the
government you've been described as Liz
truss's favorite Economist did you have
any conversations with her or her team
um well obviously the prime minister in
the last couple weeks has been
preoccupied with other issues uh but
yeah I made my thoughts uh known lots of
positives about the budget I obviously
didn't know what the detail was going to
be in it because I'm not inside the tent
so to speak but I was highlighting
indeed writing as you probably have seen
about the febrile state of the markets
and the need to keep the markets on the
side So within the overall context the
economic story is a positive one a
pro-growth agenda but there's no doubt
that in these sorts of environments as
one saw last week it was necessary to
particularly as it wasn't a budget that
was fully funded
the opr wasn't giving announcements it
was there for very important to get the
fiscal principles across last week and
they didn't they didn't take your advice
on that
well um yeah sometimes people listen
sometimes they don't but there were
positives that came out of it but
um as we saw last Friday it was just not
um keeping things into line with what
the markets had been prepped for and
were expecting